>> DEMOCRATS SOUNDING THE ALARM
ABOUT THE POTENTIAL OF A BIG RED
WAVE IN THE 2022 MIDTERM
ELECTIONS IF THE PARTY DOES NOT
FIND ITS WAY AND RESET ITS
MESSAGE AFTER ALL THAT DEFUND
THE POLICE NONSENSE THAT WAS
MADE SO PUBLIC BY THE SQUAD.
HOUSE DEMOCRATS CAMPAIGN CHIEF
WARNING BEHIND CLOSED DOORS THAT
IF THE MIDTERMS WERE HELD TODAY
REPUBLICANS WOULD WIN THE
MAJORITY IN CONGRESS.
ONE DEMOCRAT WHO ATTENDED THE
MEETING TOLD POLITICO, "THE
POLLING LOOKED PRETTY DISMAL TO
ME."
WHAT ARE YOU THINKING?
>> WELL, WE'RE STILL A VERY LONG
WAY AWAY FROM 2022.
>> SO YOU ARE SAYING DON'T JINX
IT?
>> BUT I WILL SAY IN 2020
REPUBLICANS CAME A LOT CLOSER TO
WINNING THE HOUSE THAN EVERYBODY
THOUGHT THAT THEY WOULD, OR MOST
PEOPLE ANYWAY.
THERE IS A VERY SLIM MAJORITY
WITH DEMOCRATS.
I THINK ONE OF THE SLIMMEST
MAJORITY IN THE HOUSE WITH
PELOSI, AND THEY HAVE TRIED TO
PUSH THROUGH A LOT OF FAR LEFT
WING IDEAS AND ALSO IN THE
SENATE 50-50 TAKING ADVANTAGE OF
THAT.
WHEN IT COMES TO WHAT THE ISSUES
ARE, INFLATION, OBVIOUSLY IS A
BIG ONE.
CRIME IS UP, WHEN YOU HAVE 42%
OF PEOPLE SAYING THAT THEY DON'T
THINK THAT DEMOCRATS CAN BE
TRUSTED ON THE ECONOMY, THAT'S A
BIG PROBLEM FOR DEMOCRATS GIVEN
THESE FACTORS, AND WHEN YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT PEOPLE'S
LIVELIHOODS AND CRIME AND
DEMOCRATS NOT BEING TRUSTED WITH
THAT AT ALL AND DEFUNDING THE
POLICE AND HAVING TO CRAWL BACK
FROM GOING IN ON THE DEEP END
WITH ACTIVISTS, ACTIVISTS WERE
TOTALLY IN ON DEFUNDING THE
POLICE, SO YES, THEY HAVE GOT TO
WORK ON IT.
>> WITHIN THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY,
EVEN BECAUSE THEY ARE SO
LIBERAL, PEOPLE HAVE A FALSE
IMPRESSION, I THINK, WITHIN, FOR
INSTANCE, IN THE HISPANIC
COMMUNITY.
AS IN THE AFRICAN-AMERICAN
COMMUNITY, THERE IS A LOT OF
CONSERVATISM.
A LOT OF CONSERVATIVE PEOPLE
WITHIN THESE LIBERAL GROUPS.
ONE ISSUE WHICH IS PRETTY LOCAL
IS ABOUT ISRAEL, AND SUPPORT FOR
ISRAEL.
THE SQUAD, BECAUSE -- I, IN MANY
WAYS, I AGREE WITH THEM ABOUT
THE PALESTINIANS BEING
EVEN-HANDED BUT THE JEWISH
COMMUNITY IS VERY, VERY
SUSPICIOUS.
LIKE IN CLEVELAND, WE JUST HAD
AN ELECTION FOR THE AGES.
I THINK IT BROKE ALL THE RECORDS
IN TERMS OF THE MONEY SPENT.
BROWN, THE JOE BIDEN DEMOCRAT,
AGAINST NINA TURNER, SURROGATE
FOR BERNIE SANDERS SO THERE WAS
THIS CLASH BUT NINA TURNED HER
HEAD IN THE PAST AND SAID THINGS
ABOUT ISRAEL THAT CALLED INTO
QUESTION HER LOYALTY TO ISRAEL.
BROWN WENT TO ISRAEL A COUPLE OF
YEARS AGO AND SUPPORTED THE
JEWISH STATE WITH GREAT
EMPHASIS.
YESTERDAY, WAS THE ELECTION.
TUESDAY WAS THE ELECTION.
>> LONGEST QUESTION EVER.
>> THE TURNOUT WAS VERY LOW.
13% OR SO.
THE JEWISH TURNOUT WAS MORE THAN
DOUBLE THAT.
DON'T THESE ISSUES COUNT AND
DON'T THE DEMOCRATS HAVE TO
REMEMBER WHO THEIR CONSTITUENTS
ARE?
>> THEY DO, GERALDO.
>> DO YOU REMEMBER THE QUESTION?
>> NO.
>> JOE BIDEN HAS A MESSAGING
PROBLEM AND A MANAGEMENT
PROBLEM.
THE MESSAGE WAS DURING THE
CAMPAIGN, WE HAVE TO DEFEAT THE
VIRUS AND THEN THE ECONOMY WILL
RECOVER.
WE HAVE DEFEATED THE VIRUS AND
THE ECONOMY IS RECOVERING.
BUT JOE BIDEN IS ACTING LIKE
ANYONE OF THOSE THINGS ARE TRUE.
HE'S ACTING LIKE WE HAVEN'T
BEATEN THE VIRUS.
HE'S HYPING UP DELTA.
WE'RE BACK AND FORTH ON MASKS.
AND, OH, I DON'T KNOW, ARE WE
GOING TO OPEN THE SCHOOLS,
GERALDO, AND ON THE ECONOMY, THE
ECONOMY IS SO GREAT LIKE HE'S
BRAGGING ABOUT THEN WHY ARE WE
GIVING -- WHY ARE WE SPENDING
TRILLIONS MORE IN STIMULUS.
>> THAT'S VERY POPULAR.
>> AND ALL THE SO-CALLED WAGE
GAINS THAT ARE HAPPENING ARE
OFFSET BY HIGH GAS PRICES AND
INFLATION BUT THE MANAGEMENT
ALSO IS TERRIBLE.
ON THE BORDER AND IN INNER
CITIES DEMOCRATS CONTROL BOTH
AND WE HAVE A BORDER CRISIS AND
A CRIME WAVE.
AND BLACK AMERICANS DON'T LIKE
THAT.
HISPANIC AMERICANS DON'T LIKE
SUBURBAN WOMEN DON'T LIKE THAT.
WHITE MALES.
THAT'S UNPOPULAR ACROSS THE
BOARD AND WHEN YOU THROW
CRITICAL RACE THEORY INTO THAT
MIX, THAT'S AN UPHILL CLIMB.
>> DANA, THIS DIDN'T ANSWER MY
QUESTION.
>> HE DIDN'T REMEMBER THE
>> WHAT ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE OF
REMEMBERING YOUR CONSTITUENCIES
AND ISN'T THE FEAR OF THE
SQUAD'S RADICALISM AND LACK OF
LOYALTY TO GROUPS LIKE THE
JEWISH AMERICANS, ISN'T THAT --
>> SURE.
I'LL JUST CONCEDE.
>> DANA: THAT'S AN IMPORTANT
POINT AND I'LL MAKE ANOTHER ONE.
I THINK THE DEMOCRATS REALLY
BENEFIT FROM HAVING CONGRESSMAN
SEAN PATRICK MAHONEY AS HEAD OF
THE CONGRESSIONAL ARM FOR THE
CYCLE BECAUSE HE'S WILLING TO
TELL THEM THE HARD TRUTH.
THEY LEARNED IT OUT.
EVERYBODY ON NOTICE, THAT THIS
NONSENSE COULD COST US THE
MAJORITY.
AND HE WANTED EVERYBODY TO KNOW
THAT ON TOP OF THAT, PRESIDENT
BIDEN'S NUMBERS HAVE GONE DOWN
IN A POLL THAT JUST CAME OUT
TODAY.
IN MAY, 49% APPROVAL.
TODAY, AUGUST 4, HE'S AT 46%.
ABOUT WHERE PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS.
SO HE'S LOST QUITE A BIT OF
GROUND ON THAT FRONT AND SO THE
PRESIDENT WHO IS IN POWER, IN
HIS FIRST MIDTERM, IN THE FIRST
TERM USUALLY LOSES SEATS.
THE REPUBLICANS HAVE THREE OTHER
THINGS GOING FOR THEM.
REDISTRICTING.
THAT'S PROBABLY GOING TO GIVE
THEM FIVE TO SIX SEATS.
RECRUITING.
EXCELLENT RECRUITING, AND KEVIN
McCARTHY PUTS A LOT OF EMPHASIS
ON THAT.
FUNDRAISING.
PHONE WILL BE SHORT OF MONEY.
MY LAST POINT IS THIS.
THE REPUBLICANS HAVE YET ANOTHER
ISSUE BECAUSE WHAT THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION DID YESTERDAY TO
LANDLORDS ALL ACROSS THE COUNTRY
THAT OWN 23 MILLION RENTAL
HOUSING UNITS ALL ACROSS THE
COUNTRY JUST FOUND OUT THAT THEY
WERE GOING TO GET SCREWED AGAIN.
AND THEY CAN'T GET THE HELP THAT
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT GAVE OUT
BECAUSE THE STATES DON'T KNOW
HOW TO GET IT TO THEM SO THERE
IS AN OPPORTUNITY IF THE
REPUBLICANS CAN FIGURE OUT A WAY
TO MESSAGE TO THEM AND TO GET TO
THEM THEY MIGHT BE ABLE TO GET
THOSE VOTES, TOO.
>> REPUBLICANS STILL INFLUENCED
IN A VERY PROFOUND WAY BY
PRESIDENT TRUMP IN THE SOUTHERN
PART OF OHIO.
A GUY WHO WAS A LOBBYIST, GREG,
FOR THE COAL INDUSTRY, WAS ONE
OF MANY CANDIDATES.
TRUMP WENT DOWN THERE, DID A
RALLY, AND DID GUY THAT TRUMP
ANOINTED WON, SO HE STILL HAS
SOME POTENCY.
>> THERE YOU GO.
I PREDICTED THAT YESTERDAY ON
THE SHOW, FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO
DIDN'T WATCH WITH YOU'LL NEVER
BE ABLE TO PROVE THAT.
PARTY OUT OF POWER ALWAYS COMES
ON STRONG.
THERE ARE ALWAYS RED WAVES AND
BLUE WAVES BUT THE RED WAVE IS
BASED ON THE CRIME WAVE, OF CRT
AND OTHER DENIGRATING EDUCATION
TRENDS AND THE WAVE OF CLASS
WARFARE THAT WE'RE SEEING AS
WELL WITH THIS LANDLORD --
>> AND THE BOARD.
>> THE SPENDING WAVE.
THERE ARE A LOT OF WAVES.
THE RED WAVE CAN ONLY HAPPEN IF
AMERICANS PULL THEMSELVES OUT OF
THIS DEEP RABBIT HOLE CALLED THE
SMARTPHONE.
I REALLY DO BELIEVE EXCESSES OF
THE LEFT TOOK HOLD BECAUSE WE
WERE AMBIVALENT AND DISTRACTED
BY SO MANY THINGS THAT
EVERYTHING THAT WE HATE AND WE
SHOULD HATE IN HARD CORE LEFT
POLITICS HAS BEEN ABLE TO SNEAK
IN RIGHT UNDER OUR NOSES BECAUSE
OUR NOSE WAS DO BUSY.
>> YOU'VE GOT TO SHOW UP.
IF YOU DON'T SHOW UP, THEN THERE
IS NO